former president Trump's legal
spokeswoman Alina Haba Fox News
contributor kellyanne Conway Elena I
start with you you've had a day and your
legal team has had a day to absorb all
this uh the morning after the night
before beyond the double standard what
are you thinking
I think it's been obvious I'm hoping
that the American people are picking up
on what is exactly going on I think that
it's hard not to at this point you know
I keep thinking to myself Sean what am I
going to say to the American people
outside the courthouse for indictment
number four
um you know I'm his spokeswoman I'm a
general counsel for the pack and I sit
here and and have literally litigated
tons of cases for this man and watched
how different the the courts treat him
and how the his due process rights were
frankly violated yesterday and what we
saw was an indictment come out before
the grand jury even had a chance to vote
that's Un-American it's improper and
it's obvious for a lack of better words
so
um I'm hoping the American people get it
at this point Sean I think you and I we
fight hard and and kellyanne and
everybody that goes on these programs to
try and give a little piece of reality
of what is occurring but it's up to you
to open your eyes and really see that we
have a dual system of justice it's not a
a joke and if we love this country and
we don't want to be Cuba we'd better get
out and vote in 24 and vote for the
right person kellyanne in your previous
life you were a pollster when we first
met many decades ago now and a very good
one at that there's been a phenomenon
this happens to Donald Trump as poll
numbers go up
um what happens if because I don't think
you can get a fair trial in New York I
don't think he can get a fair one in D.C
and I don't think he can get a fair one
in Fulton County that's my opinion you
know very the jury pool is prominently
dominant Democrat my question is if
there's a conviction which I would say
the odds are in favor of it based on
that jury pool if they don't got to
change a venue what what how will the
American people react to that heading
into a presidential election if he's the
nominee
Sean I'm in that business again and I
will tell you that that part of why
president Trump is way ahead of many
different Republican aspirants for the
presidential nomination is people see
him as a fighter and they see him as a
winner and they seem a little bit as a
victim because as Alina and others have
pointed out quite correctly and cogently
there's a two-tiered system of justice
and it seems like there's one for Donald
Trump and one for everyone else how in
the world can you have the most liberal
County in Georgia D.C New York City all
these places that voted against him
where he I don't think he could get a
fair trial to be frank with you and I
don't think people facing the cameras
with Glee promising to get Donald Trump
as part of their election pitch as Law
Enforcement Officers as District
Attorneys and whatnot he's got I think
he's got a lot of Runway that will allow
him to to make that argument but but let
me say this I I don't like to think of
convictions and Punishment and all that
but I I think that the country it's a
very sad moment for the country we are
in unchartered Waters and I just want to
say this voters decide who our
presidents are not District Attorneys
not big donors not anchors not pun
insult lawyers voters decide I think
that this will be litigated at The
Ballot Box all the problems with the
bidens the pro looking at Hillary
Clinton laughing and Donald Trump and
the strength he had as our as our
president for four years that will all
be part of the voter calculus in 2024.
all right thank you kellyanne Alina
thank you we'll be following all this in
today's weeks months to come hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else